hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds in
this video I want to give my opinion and
also explain the facts around life time
Isis you may have heard about life time
Isis Martin Lewis talks about life time
Isis and the government constantly
pushed lifetime Isis and here's what it
is and there's some merit to it I'm
gonna keep the pros I'm gonna give the
cons I'm gonna share my opinion but
ultimately I want to give you the
information to make up your own mind and
you can let me know your thoughts in the
comments if you have a lot of time one
sir why do you have one and if not why
did you choose not to I want to know I'm
really interested comment below here's
what it is it's an Isis or a savings
account that's specifically set up by
the government and here's what happens
if you put money in it and the
government will then match what you put
in but 25% so let's say you save up
through the ISIS a 20,000 pounds they
will then put 5,000 pounds in the
account when you are ready to go and buy
house and you have to use your one house
so that's kind of how it works you save
up 20 grand they'll give you 5 grand you
save up 40 grams they'll give you 10
grand that's then used on in deposit on
house sounds great it's basically like
free money from the government however
there are some caches you see when the
government want to give you stuff for
free or when they want to eat why would
they spend so much money advertising
lifetime answers like hey laughter I
says why would they spend money
advertising it and then give you money
to do so they clearly want you to do
something they click like call me a
cynic or a skeptic but I'm always
curious and I think the bigger reason is
is because I know the government's
bigger agenda and the government's
bigger agenda and I've done videos about
this in the past is to control
everything the super-rich the top 1% of
wealthy people what they want to do
generally speaking is they want to have
all of the money they want everything
and they don't want anyone
Financial Literacy the government want
to control everybody okay and they can't
control you unless you're poor or at
least working middle-class the education
system don't teach kids about running
why and kids about money because the
government tell them what they can and
cannot teach so they don't want you to
be financially smart they want to put
together their schemes and push you into
their skins people really get upset with
me in the comments the sale I'd show you
I had a head like Dog Show and it really
helped me listen there's some merit to
it like you say about 20 they give you
five if you're saving to buy a house
then I guess you could say it's great
let me tell you some of the catches okay
I've got some of the catches right here
number one if you change your mind so
any money that you've put into the I say
if you want it back you'll actually I've
changed my mind so you say but 20 grand
and then you go actually I don't want to
buy a house and you want the money back
you are penalized you charge 25 percent
of the money which goes straight into
the government's pocket so say what 20
grands a [ __ ] actually I want it back
you've got to pay the government five
grand
what you think they do with the money
they probably give it to the other
person that didn't want it back so
they're probably not actually giving any
money they're probably just taking off
people to change their mind and giving
it to people to stick with the program
so that's kind of extreme however
there's more catches next you cannot
save more than four grand a year so you
can only put four grand a year into this
I say interesting if you decide you
don't want to use the money for a house
to live in at all and you just think I
want that money back unless you're gonna
be prepared to get absolutely penalized
by the government and give them 25
percent you have to wait until you are
60 years old to get the money back you
have to use the money to buy a house to
live in you cannot buy a house and then
rent it out so this is not for
investment property this is you having
to live there and this is probably the
most scary okay this is I've got this
straight off off of the government
websites and stuff okay so you can check
you can check this up but
you have to agree that if a new
government comes into power they can
change the rules on what happens if your
I sir
and there's nothing you can do about it
so you are completely dependent and
reliant on the government and and the
rules so that's some of the catches so
would I do it would I input money into
an ISS no would I invest my kids to do
it
no why not I wouldn't do it because
despite there being some merit because I
want to be in control of my own life I
want to be in control of my own finances
I don't want to be told what I can do
with my money how much I can say what I
have to buy I just don't want now I want
to be free to do what I want with my
money especially when I know that the
government who were trying to control
how I invest in what I do
when I know that the government want me
to be poor so I wouldn't do it so that's
my thoughts I'd love to know your
thoughts I think this is also really
interesting point okay here's how
entrepreneurs think entrepreneurs think
fast if you want to be a property
investor you want to be successful you
want to be a businessperson fast
decisions when I was 19 years old I
bought six houses bang bang bang bang
bang a bang fast that's how you got to
be the way that the government want you
to act is very like the whole mindset
why would they say you have to own you
can only invest up to 4,000 a year
because in your mind then it's like wow
4,000 a year - max that's going to mean
I have to wait maybe six or seven years
before I can buy my first house so
straight away push back the age
everything's getting pushed back push
back the age before we buy a house the
age of new the out it's the average
person is like in their mid-20s now when
they leave home there's nothing wrong
with that but that's not that's that's
that's an on out I don't want everything
to be pushed back
I don't want retirement to be pushed
playing Playstations at my mum's house
when I'm 24
I don't want to do this I want to live
life like that I want to become
financially free it move fast go to
school and get good grades and get a
good job for life and save up money and
put it in the back we're not too much
money saves up money and put it in the
bank and then buy a house and then
invest in praat no not investing
property then pay off the mortgage of
the house and look forward to retirement
the dangling of the camera I'm not into
that life and this scheme is all about
that life so if you're if you're
thinking I'm happy nine-to-five employee
living a slow life dependent on the
government if you're happy if you want
that life then this scheme is great if
you want to be rich then this game sucks
it's terrible skin I wouldn't let my kid
to do this I just be like just work
harder and get more money fast forget
the ice that you don't want the
government to give you money you just
want to get your own money and be in
control and you don't invest in a house
to live in
invest in a property and rent where you
live that's all my thoughts
am i right unless I'm right for me and I
right for you maybe not I don't know if
I'm right for you but you can let me
know your thoughts in the comments and
I've got so much grief from the last
video I did like this not only do I get
grief from the poor people but I also
get grief from the government
I get grief from everybody because
here's the thing the media the banks the
education system the government they
don't want this message but then the
poor people don't like the message
either because they're like awesome you
users are showing up or you're too
opinionated so luckily I'm on a mission
I'm gonna because most of which people
by the way like I said before the
super-rich hide because when they become
really rich then they want all the money
me I'm making good money I made several
million
last year in Providence making very good
money but I'm not going to be controlled
to share a message with you when I don't
believe it and and some of the stuff my
Lewis teachers I mean Martin Lewis seems
like a great guy I'd love to have him on
the channel I'd love to chat with mine
but Martin Lewis is worth like 150
million and I do not believe that Martin
Lewis became worth 150 million by teeth
but by doing what he teaches I don't
believe that's how he became rich it is
not how he became rich I still do
believe that the stuff he teaches he
does himself justify teach believe me I
do myself he's a great guy but coming
from poverty mindset and trying to just
save a pound here and save apparently
sometimes if you keep worried about
saving every pound you lose the million
you know so and slow you just gotta be
fast you've got to go for the big money
you've got to think big I want to I want
to move away from this relying on people
relying on the government saving every
penny I want to get away from it because
I know that that keeps people poor and
instead of trying to save more money
sometimes you need to focus on making
more money and adding more value and
moving faster so I don't like the I
don't like the icer I don't like it let
me know your thoughts comment below
subscribe to the channel seen it